another big night for Donald Trump for
sure with a clean sweep all five states
is there any chance for other candidates
can he be stopped well Donald Trump was
just referring to Indiana there and
that's in that speech and that is where
this is going and that is really the
ultimate battleground now if he cannot
be stopped in Indiana he will not be
stopped on his way to securing this
nomination outright we can't
underestimate how he's performed tonight
when I last came to sit in this chair
there was only one County one county in
all of those five states that he wasn't
winning and that's Baltimore County in
Maryland he's won he was a way ahead in
every single other district and county
that was voting tonight so look he's had
a huge night tonight and now the stop
Trump movement what's left of the stop
Trump movement will be putting all their
chips down on Indiana next Tuesday again
Megan listen entered the Democrats now
because Hillary Clinton and now
continues to look strong where is them
Bernie Sanders headed you know the
Sanders campaign is going to have to
reevaluate he won Rhode Island tonight
so that's a bit of a consolation prize
for him but even before tonight's
results were in they were talking about
how they're going to recalibrate their
message he has it's a mathematical
impossibility almost for him to catch up
to her in terms of Delegates he says
he's going to fight through to every
vote is counted every vote is cast but
they are going to think have to think
about this message and how they want to
leave the Democratic Party they do not
want to leave the Democratic Party in a
worse place than they started they do
not want to leave the party vulnerable
to a general election to feed to Donald
Trump so I think we'll see a change in
tone from the Sanders campaign I think
we'll see some outrage between outreach
between the two camps and the day's
going forward